i'm ed grayson new york city sanitation
commissioner today i'll be answering
your questions from twitter this is
trash support
[Music]
v69 radio asks what's the craziest thing
you've ever found in the trash the most
interesting thing that i ever removed
from a cleanup site was a prosthetic leg
when we were cleaning up the aftermath
of the new york city ball drop here for
new year's eve so i always wondered how
did that person get home they clearly
made it in okay must have been a good
party night sometimes you'll see what
one would call maybe bedroom
paraphernalia inside the hopper of the
truck and it always does make you do
that wonder
but other than that everything's usually
cut and dry rosie posey asks so new york
was built on garbage
sorta not the whole thing i mean it's an
island we're really talking about the
borough manhattan for the most part
believe it or not the battery a whole
part like on the southern tip of
manhattan that was literally built on
using fill some of it was garbage some
it was earth fill but in the end of the
day that is landfill so yes parts of new
york city were in fact terraformed using
garbage and tony usgark writes you ever
just watch the robot arm of a garbage
truck hoist your refuse into the trash
trunk and think what a time to be alive
all the time my friend all the time
actually though there are some really
cool technologies on garbage trucks this
is one of our front end loaders now this
guy he's primarily used at some of our
transfer stations and we use it all the
time when we're doing debris removal and
when this arms up in the air everybody's
on high alert because this thing
probably weighs i don't know about six
thousand pounds and then it holds oh i
don't know three yards material so let's
add another three tons so anytime this
thing's swinging around you got almost
10 tons of material possibly above your
head so you're going to be looking at
that and it is a thing of wonder so here
is an iconic new york city collection
truck this thing's fantastic right here
in the back what you can get caught up
and mesmerized by is that nice sweeper
action the men and women are loading
into the back of that thing and then
they pull the handles and it is really a
ballet of sights and smells the
compactor on this will gladly eat just
about anything you put in it when you
send out our metal trucks they will
crush a washer dryer hot water heater
they'll crush just about anything mr
levenstein
ty
my girlfriend broke up with me while i
was standing next to a no dumping sign
can i sue her i don't know if that's
exactly illegal dumping that they were
talking about now most times when you
see no dumping or illegal dumping signs
out that's because the location that's
there they've had a notorious bad actor
come by quite some time and illegally
dump construction material or other
materials because they don't want to
bring it to where it's supposed to go
and i want to say this out loud now
if you're illegal dumping anywhere stop
doing that it's so easy to do the right
thing with garbage it's literally the
easiest thing to do to just follow the
local ordinances and get rid of it so
please stop illegal dumping and please
if you're listening give mr levenstein
another chance
lara 65 writes how does one properly
dispose of a knife real question seems
like tossing in the garbage is likely a
hazard for someone in waste disposal
thank you for caring we love you that's
fantastic if it's all metal it's a
recyclable product but that doesn't mean
you can't do something perhaps you could
take like a piece of plastic film tape
up where the blade is make sure that
we're really not going to get stuck
because if we don't know that it's in
there that could come out and hurt us so
thank you for thinking of us definitely
try to protect the blade but 100 metal
knife is clearly recyclable object jeff
aldridge writes new york city is an
amazing city the infrastructure the
history but why why why do they still
put trash on the streets like it's 1890
i couldn't agree with you more it is an
amazing city and the infrastructure and
the history
but there you go those are two parts of
the reason a lot of the buildings are
built to not do that we don't have a lot
of alleyways in new york city we don't
have a lot of buildings and building
spaces that have a dedicated refuse and
recycling room and we have a lot of
people and we have the charm of the city
and we have a lot of subterranean
infrastructure but we're changing we're
evolving the entire time we have
recently embarked on at least in new
york city a new pilot proposal called
clean curbs where we are going to start
installing corral areas in residential
and commercial areas normally we do from
the curb
through the parking lane into the street
where the truck is this is going to be
having the material in a sealed
container
probably ergonomic design more than
likely aesthetically beautiful much
better than looking a bunch of black
bags on the floor and then we're going
to service from there where we're going
to change possibly how much garbage you
see but just remember not seeing it
doesn't mean it's not there so we still
want to focus on is
let's get the garbage generation and all
that to be lower than it is and that'll
even make it look more like the city
that you want miss leah h asks i didn't
know how to dispose of my bacon grease
so i panicked and made a batch of gravy
instead l-o-l wellness leah h
bacon and then gravy made from bacon
we may be soul mates you did two good
things there number one you didn't pour
that grease down the drain and believe
me everybody in the sewage treatment
plant appreciates that one of the ways
that you can totally get rid of bacon
grease is
pour it into a cup put it in the freezer
turn it back into a salad and then just
throw it out jacob meshke asks why is
new york city sanitation department the
world's largest when new york isn't even
close to the largest city in the world
so are there bigger cities sure are
there places with more population sure
do they host an entire municipal
workforce that is on duty 24 hours a day
seven days a week to meet the changing
needs of the city that never sleeps and
it's 8.8 million people no they don't so
we are in charge of the refuse recycling
and snow removal all street cleaning all
special event cleaning all emergency
debris management we have a pretty
robust workload we have a really
committed city to making sure that new
york stays the gotham of the free world
and we can keep you all healthy safe and
clean
next it's timothy de la g does anyone
happen to know how much would cost to
rent a garbage truck for the day one
thing i can tell you garbage trucks are
for rent not new york city's garbage
trucks but from municipal and heavy-duty
equipment supply places you can rent a
garbage truck right now in new york city
our average you know iconic white
garbage truck that you see going on has
to house crypt to curb it's a little
over 250 000 per truck because it's got
the highest level of technology we use
renewable diesel we have a lot of things
built in there to make sure that we're
one of the most sustainable fleets
across the country but i can tell you
this much it's going to cost you a lot
for a garbage truck i'd say you may want
to let the professionals handle that one
machine gun kelly asks where does all
the new york city trash go after trucks
pick it up i'm worried where does it go
it goes to one of our many transfer
stations where from there it gets
processed sorted and then taken to a
final destination in new york city we
host about five different transfer
stations four by barge one by rail and
we have a myriad of recycling contract
vendors we bring the recyclable
materials from there it makes its
sorting process and then moves on to
either landfill waste energy plant or
proper recycling for beneficial reuse
next up
aquila obviously can i ask something how
are we supposed to be throwing batteries
away it all depends on where you live
you should really check your local
ordinances because they may have a
different waste management plan but if
you're in new york right now and you
have let's say small disposable alkaline
batteries because there's no mercury in
them you can actually put them out in
the trash certain batteries like let's
say automotive batteries here in new
york they have to go back to wherever
you bought that so if it's a retailer
that sells an automotive battery they
have to take it back and then they'll
properly recycle it some of the lithium
ion batteries and you know the more
rechargeable ones they can be pretty
dangerous and we want them a safe handle
also you can go to like the new york
city website nyc.gov
sanitation and we have this great portal
where we tell you how do i dispose of
and you can find out all the different
ways that you can dispose of not only
batteries but a bunch of other stuff
that people have those lingering
questions on think shiv why does nyc
sanitation only pick up recyclable
materials once a week if they increased
it i would recycle more hashtag just
saying it comes down to trying to
effectively and efficiently route
throughout the entire city we know
pretty much on average how much
recycling is going to be out on every
block face and we use a lot of data and
trend analysis to know exactly how many
trucks are on in the city with 8.8
million people though we are trying to
root efficiently make sure that we're
getting out there hitting every
community board fairly and equitably and
giving everybody the same opportunity to
recycle us trying to get more
opportunity for each resident that's one
of the long-term goals tristan convert
asks how does recycling actually work
what do you think i think that the big
cornerstone on recycling it makes us
conscious about how we're behaving we go
out every day and we pick up you know a
thousand tons of paper in new york city
and we bring that back and that's going
to a paper mill and that mixed paper is
getting re-pulped remanufactured and
we're making new things we're making
things like pizza boxes we're making
things like recycled paper more and more
and more you're seeing sustainable ways
that we can do beneficial reuse for some
of the things that are totally
consumables metal recycling for example
you know all those cans and all the the
bulk metal that's going to be sorted by
metal type and re-smelted back into
things to make new things that's the
ultimate goal one of the ideas that we
have to hold true is that recycling is
not a bad thing if we can keep it out of
the landfill while we're working on the
next way to find ways to make better
products have more sustainable packaging
to begin with that's the real answer
pooja vixen writes what do landfills do
with garbage what do landfills do with
garbage they hold it for us usually
modern-day landfilling involves
high-tech design landfill with
industrial and environmental protection
base layers underneath silt layers
drainage runoff caps all kinds of seals
and you know sub-terrain infrastructure
so that everything's done in an
environmentally sustainable way and then
as it biodegrades you're building up
methane that methane is going to be
pumped out and put the beneficial use
usually as energy and then all along the
way what you're going to do is you're
going to be capping at different
intervals so there'll be an active bank
where the garbage being dumped and then
they'll keep moving the herd around to
try to level out the playing field until
it runs out of room and then people say
well then what happens then what you're
going to do then is you're going to seal
up the landfill and you're going to
monitor that for anywhere from 30 plus
years and then usually what happens is
that's when you could start looking to
use that land again for something other
than being a waste disposal site
yalawale asks where will the trash go
when all the landfills are full
great question because it hits on why
does everybody think zero waste reuse in
recycling some of the greatest time of
of actual individual recycling and
recapture rate during the world war one
world war ii efforts when we were
literally trying to get back all the
metal and you know our grandparents and
great grandparents would tell us all the
stories about how they were saving
everything and bringing in all the tin
cans from the local neighborhood because
they really thought they had to get all
these materials back in so that they
could you know preserve our way of life
well guess what folks we need to
preserve our way of life right now what
are we gonna do in the landfills run out
exactly we're gonna have all this
garbage no place to bring it that's why
trying to reduce consumption learn
everything we can do to be living a
recyclable life finding beneficial reuse
for these products and more importantly
thinking so where does it go i think
that's entirely up to us let's work on
that together shabazz jab says i feel
like it's trash day every day in new
york city like how does everybody have
this much garbage that's what i'm saying
but the reality of it is is that every
year we're doing on the residential side
a little over three million tons away of
material every day is trash day because
every single person is consuming
something and whether you think about it
or not you have created your own
personal piece of the waste stream every
single day can we do stuff that'll make
that different absolutely maybe we don't
have to buy as much maybe not throw out
half the strawberries because you didn't
get to them for the smoothie think about
those things you can consume less you
can generate less waste and then maybe
every day won't feel like garbage day
dorky mark writes what is waste
segregation it's just another word for
sorting so what does that mean a lot of
places are going to ask you to source
separate your material we do it here in
new york city we're asking all of the
residents to source separate their paper
and their mgp and then a handful of
community boards here we're asking to
separate their organic waste before they
put it out so that we can come and
properly delineate it so we could take
it to the respective stream jurors devil
2000 asks will composting ever work in
new york absolutely it works everywhere
the question is will we do enough to
make it work can we get it scalable and
i have to tell you we're on our way
there we have to do this incredible
thing as a city and try to remind
ourselves of why we're doing it because
what we're going to do there is going to
turn into nutrient-dense compost we're
going to take all that food waste and
we're going to segregate it we're going
to put it into places where it can
become nutrient dense compost because
that doesn't have to go to a landfill
it's completely wasting all of that
beautiful energy that happens as it
breaks down will composting work yes
it's going to take people like you who
care it's going to take people in the
positions that make those decisions on a
municipal level and the government level
to give you the access to those programs
and the education but can we do it
absolutely great question all right
that's it i hope you learned something
and you had fun until next time